[Aplausos]
[Música]
este tema
camps
jon hamm
no vengáis no vengáis queridos amigos
amigas las relaciones entre los eeuu y
latinoamérica
pues nunca fueron fáciles no siempre han
sido cordiales y no está del todo claro
cuál de las dos partes ha tenido menos
ilusión por ir de la mano con la otra
dicho de otra forma esta relación ha
sido siempre menos romántica que una
película de sylvester stallone desde
principios del siglo 20 el único interés
que realmente washington ha tenido en
sus vecinos del sur ha sido casi en
exclusiva el de alinearlos a sus propios
intereses geopolíticos e ideológicos
algo que se vio reforzado a partir de
los años 60 con la llegada del comunismo
a cuba- en plena guerra fría desde
entonces washington no dudó en apoyar a
cuantos dictadores grupos paramilitares
o malhechores que estuvieran dispuestos
a cuadrarse ante el 'tío sam'
[Música]
fuera como fuese lo cierto es que el
papel o la injerencia de eeuu ha pasado
por diferentes etapas y la última a la
del ex presidente de donald trump fue
quizás una de las más distantes de todas
y eso que dejó declaraciones como esta
cuando venezuela sea libre y cuba sea
libre y nicaragua sea libre este se
convertirá en el primer hemisferio libre
en toda la historia de la humanidad ha
llegado la última hora del socialismo
nuestro hemisferio los días del
socialismo están contados no sólo en
venezuela sino en nicaragua y en cuba-
donald trump sin embargo llegará la hora
de la verdad pues como expresar lo
digamos que trump nunca llegó a
manifestar mucho interés por américa
latina'
al menos no un interés mayor que el que
tiene un vegano por un chuletón de kilo
y medio pero un momento porque ahora las
cosas han cambiado hay un nuevo
inquilino en la casa blanca un
presidente con ideas y experiencias muy
distintas y del que se espera intente
jugar de nuevo las cartas de la
disputada competición latinoamericana
por eso en visual política nos hemos
hecho unas cuantas preguntas qué cambios
puede traer consigo la nueva
administración más allá de la cuestión
mexicana que tiene un rol propio cuáles
son los temas clave que están sobre la
mesa y quizás la pregunta más importante
de todas qué pasa con china volver
latinoamérica convertirse en el campo de
juego de una nueva contienda global
atentos por cierto apunte si queréis
saber más sobre latinoamérica no os
podéis perder la tam política nuestra
newsletter dedicada exclusivamente a
esta región os dejo toda la información
por aquí abajo en la descripción mochila
al hombro
[Música]
los amigos durante las últimas
elecciones presidenciales de los estados
unidos dos de cada tres latinos votaron
por joe bailes sin embargo no esa no es
ni mucho menos la principal razón por la
que se espera que latinoamérica adquiera
más peso en la política exterior
norteamericana y es que lo cierto es que
yo vaivenes el inquilino del despacho
oval que más conocimiento tiene sobre la
región para que os hagáis una idea tan
sólo durante su etapa como
vicepresidente de barack obama va a ir
en visitó la región ni más ni menos que
en 16 ocasiones nunca antes un
presidente o un vicepresidente había
visitado tantas veces a américa latina y
lógicamente eso pues no es algo
anecdótico sí y donald trump consideraba
a la región como algo insignificante por
así
como una especie de pozo que solo le
daba quebraderos de cabeza para bailén
es un escenario juego que además conoce
de primera mano y para bien o para mal
eso es algo que se ha manifestado desde
el primer momento por ejemplo ha
nombrado a juan sebastián gonzález un
tipo nacido en colombia como el nuevo
director de asuntos hemisféricos en el
consejo de seguridad nacional esto es el
hombre fuerte del presidente para los
asuntos de latinoamérica pero por
supuesto los cambios no se limitaron a
un nombramiento prácticamente nada más
aterrizar en la casa blanca el nuevo
equipo de gobierno anunció cambios
importantes
[Música]
en primer lugar la administración baiden
abandona la política planteada por tram
y un segundo eje del mal integrado por
venezuela cuba y nicaragua lo que según
parece significa que la cuestión
venezolana o cubana ya no serán la única
preocupación de washington es decir para
entendernos que formar parte del frente
común contra este eje del mal ya no
eximirá de las posibles críticas del
gigante norteamericano eso es por
ejemplo lo que ocurrió nada más llegar
al poder el nuevo equipo de la
secretaria de estado cuando hizo público
que seguía de cerca el intento del
congreso de guatemala de colocar en la
corte constitucional a un juez acusado
de obstrucción a la justicia o también
cuando han manifestado su inquietud por
la violencia contra activistas por los
derechos humanos en colombia
en segundo lugar se anunció que cuba
será excluida de la lista de estados
patrocinadores del terrorismo luego
veremos la cuestión con más detalle y la
tercera decisión que rápidamente tuvo el
boe equipo de gobierno fue acordar la
concesión del estatus de protección
temporal a más de 300.000 venezolanos
exiliados en el país es decir en otras
palabras que todo apunta a que veremos
una administración mucho más activa más
exigente e inclusiva a los asuntos
locales pero por supuesto los dos
primeros temas los dos temas estrella en
la agenda latinoamericana de
absolutamente todos los presidentes de
eeuu desde hace ya varias décadas no son
otros que la inmigración y la lucha
contra el narcotráfico así que la
primera pregunta que nos podemos hacer
es exactamente cuál es la posición de la
administración byd en respecto a la
inmigración y el narcotráfico pues
atentos la inmigración y narcos al
cuadrado vale donald trump fue uno de
los presidentes de eeuu más hostiles a
la inmigración de las últimas décadas y
eso eso es algo que yo baiden ha dicho
por activa y por pasiva que se va a
terminar claro que la consecuencia de
lanzar ese tipo de mensajes puede ser
exacta
y la que no quieres 32 de marzo de 2021
la frontera sur saturada así se llegó a
la primera crisis migratoria de la de
nabai de amigos el impacto de la
pandemia en países ya de por sí muy
pobres junto a la nueva posición de la
administración vaivén sobre la
inmigración y algunas de las medidas que
ya han tomado como por ejemplo la
suspensión de la política quédate en
mexico una política que obligaba a los
solicitantes de asilo en eeuu a
permanecer en el país mexicano hasta
regularizar su situación ha provocado
una nueva ola migratoria el 17 de marzo
del 2021 estamos en vías de registrar
más personas en la frontera sur que en
los últimos 20 años alejandro mayorkas
jefe del departamento de seguridad
interior lo ven como el presidente de
los migrantes y por eso muchos sienten
que van a llegar a eeuu a andrés manuel
lópez obrador presidente de mexico por
ejemplo la decisión de no deportar a los
menores no acompañados pues ha provocado
que ahora estos lleguen en masa la cifra
de menores no acompañados que llegan a
eeuu marca récords cerca de 19 mil niños
migrantes sin acompañantes llegaron a
eeuu tras cruzar la frontera con mexico
durante marzo se trata de la mayor cifra
mensual que jamás se haya registrado en
el país y claro es entonces cuando de
repente nos encontramos con mensajes
como estos no vengan pide you by den a
migrantes el presidente estadounidense
instó los indocumentados que
protagonizan la última oleada migratoria
que se queden en sus países
en este cuarto
algunas reflexiones región
méxico
am
en air facebook y en youtube importarlos
en este sector el poder
pero la pregunta es que planes concretos
tiene en mente el nuevo gobierno para
enfrentarse a este problema y otra
cuestión muy importante por qué demonios
hablamos de inmigración si este es un
vídeo sobre baile y latinoamérica pues
queridos amigos la razón tiene que ver
con la nueva estrategia de la casa
blanca digamos que el nuevo
planteamiento del gobierno de eeuu es
que tanto en la inmigración como en
buena medida la proliferación del
narcotráfico tiene mucho que ver
esencialmente con la situación local del
país de procedencia esto es con la falta
de oportunidades la ausencia de
seguridad y la poca fortaleza de las
instituciones locales para hacer frente
a los problemas y entienden que es
exactamente en estos puntos donde tienen
que trabajar por ejemplo cuando hablamos
de inmigración además de méxico hablamos
necesariamente de lo que eeuu denomina
el triángulo norte guatemala el salvador
y honduras son tres de los países más
pobres de toda américa latina' países
con problemas muy pero que muy serios a
altísimas tasas de violencia a pandillas
corrupción masiva e incluso políticos
con lazos directos con el narcotráfico
ahí estaba por ejemplo el caso del
mismísimo presidente de honduras juan
orlando hernández del que ya os hemos
hablado en varias ocasiones en visual
político
de esta forma el planteamiento de
washington es que si las condiciones de
vida mejoran en estos países entonces
habrá menos inmigración irregular y
también será más fácil controlar el
narcotráfico por eso by then apuesta por
retomar la estrategia que barack obama
puso en marcha en 2016 la conocida como
alianza para la prosperidad del
triángulo norte un programa que recibió
750 millones de dólares en 2016 pero que
luego bajo la administración trump se
fue reduciendo año tras año en total el
presupuesto asignado superó los 2 mil
millones de dólares entre 2016 y 2020 un
dinero que supuestamente se utilizó para
financiar proyectos para impulsar el
desarrollo y mejorar las condiciones de
vida locales
pues bien ahora yo vaya den ha
presentado un plan para impulsar de
nuevo esta política con cuatro mil
millones de dólares durante cuatro años
mil millones por año un plan al frente
del cual ha situado por cierto a la
vicepresidenta kamala harris que es
exactamente lo que obama hizo con el
propio binner cuando fui vicepresidente
me centre en proporcionar la ayuda
necesaria para abordar estas causas
fundamentales de la migración ayudó a
mantener a la gente en sus propios
países en lugar de obligarla a marcharse
nuestro plan funcionó
joe biden el problema amigos el problema
es que a pesar de las afirmaciones de
bailén no está del todo claro que el
programa realmente funcionará la idea
tenía sentido pero lo cierto es que los
resultados fueron muy pero que muy
pobres durante 2019 2020 y 2021 la
inmigración a eeuu se ha disparado de
nuevo y por ejemplo en guatemala un país
que ha recibido más de 1600 millones de
dólares en ayuda de eeuu durante los
últimos 10 años los índices de pobreza
han aumentado la desnutrición se ha
convertido en un problema real y la
corrupción pues camps a sus anchas
quizás el problema es que el plan
estuviera mal planteado por ejemplo se
calcula que las empresas que lo pilotaba
se quedaban con cerca del 50 por ciento
del presupuesto en concepto
los salarios y gastos burocráticos es un
negocio los mismos ejecutores ganan los
contratos una y otra vez a pesar de
haber sido malos ejecutores en el pasado
sin mostrar ningún nivel de impacto y
sin cambiar nada a carlos ponce profesor
de gestión empresarial en la universidad
de columbia pero de todo esto lo haremos
largo y tendido en un próximo vídeo que
ya estamos preparando y que estamos
convencidos no os dejará indiferentes
así que ya sabéis no olvidéis
suscribiros al politics si aún no lo
habéis hecho luego en colombia' el
epicentro junto a méxico del problema de
los narcóticos bailén ha pedido al
congreso elevará hasta los 453 millones
de dólares anuales la ayuda para luchar
contra el narcotráfico una cantidad
sustancialmente superior a la media de
330 millones destinada por trump durante
sus últimos tres presupuestos hablamos
como veis de una política de dotación de
fondos que encaja con esa visión más
intervencionista que parece defender la
nueva casa blanca en su continente
hermano pero por supuesto aquí no queda
todo
sueños de caracas y la habana
la política hacia cuba es siempre una de
las más controvertidas y con más coste
político de toda la diplomacia
norteamericana no olvidéis sin ir más
lejos lo que ocurrió en las pasadas
elecciones presidenciales del 2020
cuando la minoría cubana en florida le
dio la espalda al presidente y se
inclinó mayoritariamente por trampa y lo
hizo porque pensaban que bailén estaba
dispuesto a retomar la política de
distensión que en su día ya puso en
marcha barack obama una política que fue
conocida como la diplomacia del béisbol
sin embargo parece que bailén aprendió
la lección cuando obama tendió la mano
al régimen castrista en busca de un
cambio y este pues casi le muerde la
mano de esta forma parece que la
posición será bastante pasiva es decir
que muevan ficha en la habana y sean
ellos quienes demuestren activamente que
están dispuestos a iniciar una cierta
transición política y económica aún así
lo que sí quiere hacer la casa blanca es
dejar la puerta abierta
el equipo de bailén tiene decidido
revertir la inclusión de cuba en la
lista de países patrocinadores del
terrorismo que llevó a cabo en sus
últimos días de mandato la
administración trump asimismo también se
da por hecho que frenar a la puesta en
marcha de la ley helms burton cuyo
título tercero permite que los
ciudadanos norteamericanos demanden a
las empresas internacionales que
utilicen o se beneficien de las
propiedades confiscadas por el régimen
de fidel castro- esta es una norma que
fue suspendida desde 1996 por todos los
presidentes pero que trump decidió
activar como medida en 2019 además ante
la mala situación de la economía cubana
y para impulsar la apertura el equipo de
bailén pretende levantar los límites que
existen a las remesas y los viajes a la
isla y respecto a venezuela pues tres
cuartas partes de lo mismo que sean
ellos quienes muevan ficha pero dicho
esto más allá del cada vez más
debilitado bloque cubano venezolano y
junto a la política respecto a
centroamérica hay otra cuestión que
preocupa y mucho a washington ni más ni
menos que el miedo a la influencia china
[Música]
la conquista de oriente
a ver si hay un tema que últimamente
hace saltar todas las alarmas en
washington ese es precisamente el de la
influencia china en el resto del mundo y
no importa si hablamos del pacífico' de
europa de áfrica o de latinoamérica esta
última una región por cierto en la que
los últimos años la influencia china no
ha parado de crecer
china devora literalmente las materias
primas de la acción ha invertido mucho
en sectores como la energía o las
infraestructuras autopistas y puertos y
eso parece ser lo que ahora badén quiere
contrarrestar la estrategia de vaivén
será ofrecer financiamiento alternativo
para sectores críticos de
infraestructura que incluye aspectos
claves como las telecomunicaciones
benjamin guedán director del programa
latinoamericano del wilson center sin
embargo un momento porque la jugada más
importante la jugada clave para
contrarrestar el creciente peso de china
en la región y al mismo tiempo apoyar a
los países más próximos a eeuu no sería
otra que regresar al pp ahora también
conocido como cpp el acuerdo de libre
comercio transpacífico más avanzado al
que por ejemplo como ya os contamos
recientemente incluso el reino unido ha
pedido su atención y eso eso es
exactamente con lo que ahora se especula
en washington
e integrarse de nuevo en este acuerdo
comercial tendría dos consecuencias
directas por un lado un espaldarazo a la
alianza del pacífico cuyos integrantes
forman parte de este acuerdo y por otro
estrechar los lazos entre eeuu y
latinoamérica además supondría poner
punto y final a una de las políticas más
características de la era trap la del
proteccionismo comercial queridos amigos
amigas estos son los principales temas
que están en la agenda latinoamericana
de joe bayern pero llegado hasta aquí
turno para ti qué crees que supondrá la
administración bailén para latinoamérica
cuál será su influencia déjanos tu
respuesta por aquí abajo en los
comentarios y ya sabes si este vídeo te
resultó interesante
no olvides darle a like y suscribirte a
visual político una vez más muchas
gracias por estar ahí un saludo hasta la
próxima
[Música]